[Música]
hola a todos
en
decidí a hacer este vídeo porque
llevaba meses preparando una plática
para te toca
mi presentación era en dos semanas en un
auditorio de 600 personas en la ibero
evidentemente se canceló
pero decidí compartir mi plática a
través de este vídeo porque
me parece importante
para el momento que estamos viviendo en
todo el planeta
en donde el miedo está acechando en
nuestros hogares y creo que es
importante hablar de eso
ah
mi plática es
mi historia de vida resumida pero mi
historia nunca había compartido mi
historia de vida y
y creo que es importante compartir
nuestras historias así los demás pueden
aprender de nuestros errores y aciertos
y no sé quizá escuchar mi historia en
estos momentos le sirva de algo
la mayoría de gente no me conoce algunos
conocen la imagen detrás del nombre
bárbara mori pero
no me conocen a mí
gran parte de mi vida estuve tratando de
pertenecer
de encontrar un lugar en el mundo que me
permitirá salirme de la realidad que me
acompañó toda mi infancia
una realidad oscura triste alejada del
amor
entonces buscaba un lugar seguro
y aunque nunca fui amante del dinero ya
que nunca lo tuve
mi entorno mis amistades mis compañeros
e incluso mi propia familia me empujaban
hacia esa dirección
a los 14 años empecé a trabajar como
mesera para poder ahorrar y escaparme de
la violencia que vivía en mi casa pero
con lo que ganaba no me alcanzaba para
ahorrar más adelante ya con 17 años
logré salir me hice de todo un poco
repartir volantes en los semáforos fui
bailarina en un antro bartender
también trabajé de secretaria en una
agencia de modelos y ahí mi físico me
ayudó a entrar al mundo al modelaje
pero al principio no fue nada fácil
porque no me quedaba en nada
y hasta que logré hacer mis primeros
comerciales como extra descubrí con
tristeza que las agencias se generaban
el dinero así que había veces que pagaba
mi renta o comía
y estando frente a las cámaras fue como
descubrir que quería ser actriz así que
me metí a estudiar actuación y empezó mi
carrera
durante 10 años estuve actuando en
telenovelas sin parar y en medio de
todos esos proyectos luchaba por
encontrarme
no era muy consciente de por qué de mi
enojo contra la vida y mi necesidad de
demostrar no sólo a los demás sino
también a mí misma que yo tenía en un
valor
al crecer rodeada de golpes y abuso
psicológico se generó en mí la creencia
de que yo no era lo suficientemente
buena en nada como para haber merecido
el amor de mis padres
y creía que no merecía el buen trato de
nadie ni siquiera de mí
y va por la vida generando situaciones
absolutamente destructivas con las
decisiones que iba tomando
que motivaban estas decisiones el miedo
el miedo a que a la idea porque era
solamente una idea de que yo no merecía
el amor
así que en medio de toda esta
turbulencia emocional me refugio en mi
carrera
y después de interpretar los mismos
personajes sumisos como protagonista me
empecé a sentir estancada como actriz lo
cual generó en mí una inmensa necesidad
de empezar a hacer otras cosas para
seguir creciendo como actriz así que fue
ahí cuando llegó rubí a mi vida
el proyecto implicaba un riesgo distinto
del personaje por eso acepté hacerla eso
sí bajo mis condiciones porque la
empresa quería firmar me como exclusiva
por seis años y me dijeron que si no
firmaba con ellos buscarían alguien más
y yo estaba absolutamente segura de que
no le daría seis años de mi vida a
seguir haciendo lo mismo quería hacer
cine
en ese momento los actores de televisión
no éramos bien recibidos en ese mundo
pero yo quería intentarlo porque sabía
que el cine me daría la oportunidad de
hacer cosas distintas
así que en contra de todos los consejos
rechace la oferta y me llevé una gran
sorpresa
cuando aún así accedieron a firmarme
solo por ese proyecto
ahí entendí que cuando te sales de esa
famosa zona de confort arriesgándolo
todo para ir en busca de tus sueños lo
que generas es un sinfín de
posibilidades que te acercan a ellos
rubí fue el proyecto más importante del
momento me trajo una proyección
internacional que nunca imaginé era
poseedora de esas tres cosas que según
la sociedad te llevan a la felicidad era
famosa exitosa y me pagaban muy bien
sin embargo yo llegaba a mi camerino
cerraba la puerta me miraba al espejo
y me ponía a llorar
me sentía sola vacía triste
lo cual me llevó a tener una
profundísima reflexión
y todo el dinero ni toda la fama ni todo
el éxito jamás nos va a llevar a la
felicidad si por dentro estamos rotos
a mí me rompieron de niña
mi padre con su adicción y violencia y
mi madre con su abandono
entonces entendí que para encontrar la
felicidad tenía que empezar a mirar
hacia adentro
y aprendí a meditar
y después de años de hacer un trabajo
interno profundo un día me di cuenta que
estaba llena de patrones de conducta y
creencias impuestas por mis padres mis
amigos la sociedad
estas creencias me dieron una identidad
a lo largo de mi vida que me empujó a
actuar muchas veces sin darme cuenta que
estaba construyendo un camino que no
quería construir
y también descubrí que no estaba tan de
acuerdo con esas creencias
y lo más importante que yo tenía el
poder de cambiar
a ver todos somos luz y oscuridad
no existe la una sin la otra no podemos
deshacernos de nuestra oscuridad porque
es parte de nuestra condición humana lo
que sí podemos hacer
es elegir qué parte alimentar
el miedo que viene de la oscuridad o el
amor que viene de la luz
yo alimentaba el miedo todo el tiempo
por eso estaba enojada con la vida así
que empecé a alimentar el amor que hay
en mí
y eso me llevó a entrar en contacto con
mis emociones
y poco a poco empecé a tomar otro tipo
de decisiones
lo cual me empujó a vivir nuevas
aventuras entonces mis creencias se han
ido reemplazando por experiencias de
vida
la intuición
es la voz que viene desde nuestro
corazón y saber escuchar le es de gran
ayuda para tomar decisiones
a mí me ayudó mucho en un momento clave
en mi vida en donde a raíz del éxito de
ruby la empresa me buscó para que
firmara con ellos a cambio de cualquier
cosa que yo pidiera ojo es una oferta
tentadora si lo que estás buscando es
enriquecer tus bolsillos y asegurar tu
futuro cómo muchos me lo dijeron en su
momento
pero siempre he sido fiel a mis sueños
a mis necesidades más profundas ya mis
ganas de seguir aprendiendo
así que rechace la oferta a pesar de
todas las dudas que se generaron en mí
al escuchar la voz de mi ego que me
decía no bárbara no la calles las
oportunidades así se dan solamente una
vez en la vida
cuántas veces no hemos escuchado eso
la voz de mi corazón me decía que no
que fuera en busca de mi crecimiento
personal
de mi crecimiento como artista que sin
duda me llevaría a un crecimiento
personal
vivir la vida a través del corazón nos
muestra un camino más amoroso
nos conecta con nuestra sabiduría
interna que nunca se equivoca y todo
cambia
cambia el enfoque cambia la visión la
forma en la que nos relacionamos con el
mundo exterior la manera en la que nos
tratamos a nosotros mismos
y nos ayuda a ser pacientes con nuestro
proceso de vida ya no juzgarnos tanto
que somos buenísimos para juzgarnos
ahora cómo saber si es la voz de mi ego
la que me habla o es mi corazón es muy
complejo
pero
y quizá esta idea pueda ayudar
partiendo de qué
todas las decisiones que tomamos todos
los días la determinación de dar o no
dar de unir o dividir
cualquier pensamiento palabra o acción
viene del amor o del miedo
si pensamos bien cuál de las dos impulsa
esta voz
quizá ahí encontremos la respuesta
lo que pasa es que nos han enseñado a
vivir en el temor
la educación que hemos tenido por años y
años está diseñada así conforme a un
sistema que necesita controlarnos para
poder manejarnos a su antojo y así poder
seguir enriqueciendo a los que lo
manejan
la forma más fácil de controlar a
alguien es haciéndolos débil ignorante
impartiéndole miedo enferman dolo
por eso el sistema educativo tradicional
es uno de los principales problemas que
enfrentamos en estos tiempos
somos empujados al consumismo porque el
sistema necesita gente infeliz que
consuman sus productos con la idea de
que sus vidas van a mejorar
al sistema no le sirve gente despierta
que nos cuestionemos cosas como quiénes
somos porque estamos aquí aquí venimos
qué pasa con el mundo por qué tanta
violencia y tanto odio
pero claro cómo vamos a tener este tipo
de reflexiones y cuestionamientos si
estamos todo el día distraídos en el
celular esperando tener la cantidad de
likes que necesitamos porque necesitamos
la aprobación de los demás porque si no
estamos ansiosos deprimidos
hoy
dependiendo del número de nuestros
seguidores miden nuestro valor a mí eso
me parece aterrador
porque el valor de cada uno de nosotros
está en el ser que llevamos dentro
así que si utilizamos la tecnología a
nuestro favor
y no permitimos que ésta nos envuelva en
ese torbellino destructivo que amenaza
seriamente nuestro crecimiento
espiritual
pensaremos una gran pantalla
no hay que olvidar que donde ponemos
nuestra atención florece
cuando yo llevé mi atención adentro de
mi ser de mi ser empecé a sanar mis
heridas
aprendí a amarme
el amor propio es lo más poderoso para
enfrentar las crueldades del mundo
y yo estoy segura que todos tenemos
heridas todos tenemos un momento en
nuestra vida donde fuimos rotos
quizá en nuestros años más tempranos
donde algo o alguien generó una herida o
varias
y estas heridas necesitan sanar
sanar nos ayuda a conocernos
a entender a saber qué es lo que
quisiéramos hacer con nuestras vidas
de verdad queremos seguir construyendo
una vida basada en lo que nos dijeron
que tenía que ser
o queremos ir mejor en busca de nuestros
sueños
hay que atreverse a soñar
tener coraje y tomar riesgos
hay que ser congruentes
hasta encontrar un balance en donde lo
que hacemos decimos y pensamos sea lo
que somos
y yo sé que no es fácil pero se puede
aprender
yo cometí muchos errores tratando de
encontrar mi propio camino y lo sigo
cometiendo muchos
pero estos errores me enseñan me llevan
a enfrentarme con el mundo ya darme
cuenta que vivir está en mis manos
y que las decisiones que voy tomando
construyen mi futuro
pero claro por dónde empezar
yo siempre he tenido la necesidad de
acabar con el odio con la violencia
con la injusticia
la desigualdad el racismo
las guerras la pobreza el hambre
tantas y tantas cosas que han cooperado
para la destrucción de la vida de la
libertad
el amor
ya entendí que nada de eso está en mi
control
lo que sí está en mi control es lo que
yo hago con mi vida
mahatma gandhi decía que el cambio que
quieres ver en el mundo
así que yo empecé a generar cambios en
mí
empecé a meditar
hacer yoga retiros espirituales al leer
yo odiaba la lectura porque mi papá me
obligaba a leer y cuando llegaba a casa
y no sabía decirle lo que había leído me
reventaba la cara contra la tarea así
que odiaba la lectura pero me esforcé a
leer porque porque sé lo importante que
es el conocimiento
me metí a clases de historia filosofía
psicología para entender quiénes somos y
cómo funcionamos
emprendí una búsqueda de mí misma
hasta que logré entender lo que decía en
mi corazón y porque eso sentía tan roto
tan lastimado
entendí lo importante que es crear desde
la conciencia pensando en el bien común
justo en estos momentos estamos viviendo
un momento de despertar para toda la
humanidad
es importante ir a nuestro corazón y
tomar decisiones desde ahí
no conectarnos con el miedo y el pánico
colectivo que está generando el
coronavirus
hay que darnos cuenta donde estamos
parados como humanidad y tomar acción
siendo amorosos generosos compasivos con
nosotros mismos y con los demás
dejar de pensar solamente lo que
nosotros necesitamos ya que fuimos
enseñados a sobresalir por encima del
otro
si no es el camino
hay que entendernos una mano
para ayudarnos a crecer unidos
y generar bienestar en la humanidad que
hace tanta falta
no fue desde esta necesidad que hace
siete años abrí una fundación junto con
óscar aguirre
amor infinito es una fundación con la
que nos encargamos de hacerle los sueños
realidad a los niños que se están
muriendo o que están atravesando por
alguna enfermedad terminal
esta fundación es una de tantas formas
de regresarle a la vida un poquito de lo
mucho que me ha dado
porque a pesar de que me rompieron por
dentro sino tan pequeña y me ha costado
tanto trabajo juntar mis pedacitos
estoy muy agradecida por poder estar de
pie
consciente y convencida de que todo lo
que nos sucede trae detrás un gran
aprendizaje
hemos cumplido el sueño de muchos niños
con amor infinito
y hemos dibujado sonrisas en caritas que
parecían ya no tener esperanza
también hemos visto muchos partidos
incluso antes de llevarles su sueño a
cabo
y hemos aprendido mucho de estos
chiquitos
uno siempre se queja por tonterías
pero cuando ves la realidad de
tantísimas personas en donde su vida
pende de un hilo
te das cuenta dónde está el valor de las
cosas que realmente importan
nietzsche escribió
el que da de comer al que tiene hambre
que conforta su propia alma
y no es el fin
eres el resultado
así que hoy con la vida que me he
construido soy muy feliz y estoy muy
agradecida
si volteaba hacia atrás
solo puedo sentir agradecimiento hacia
esa niña que fui
a pesar de las circunstancias nunca dejo
de creer nunca deje de escuchar a mi
corazón
sanar mis heridas me llevo a rescatarme
a mirarme de frente y pedirme perdón
y jurar me que nunca más dejaré que
nadie pase por encima de mí
mañana
mañana quién sabe
todo depende de las decisiones y las
semillas que plante hoy
trabajemos juntos unidos
en estos momentos en donde la humanidad
necesita nuestra unión porque la unión
hace la fuerza
gracias y espero que les sirva
esta historia y este vídeo
[Música]
[Aplausos]